قال وزير الدفاع الايراني محمد رضا
اشتياني ان لدى بلاده علاقات جيده مع
الصين وانها تبحث بيع مسيرات ايرانيه
اليها واضاف اشتياني ان العلاقات بين
بلاده والصين وروسيا يمكن ان تحد من
الاحاديه الامريكيه والغربيه بحسب وصفه
واكد الوزير الايراني ان بلاده لم تتسلم
بعد طائرات سخوي 35 روسيه وانها ليست
بحاجه لشراء انظمه دفاع صاروخي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق تاتي
تصريحات وزير الدفاع الايراني بشان خصوصيه
علاقات بلاده العسكريه مع الصين وما مغزى
كشفه عن بيعها مسيرات ايرانيه في هذا
التوقيت
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم التقارب العسكري
بين طهران وبيجين وموسكو وما المدى الذي
يمكن ان يصل اليه وما الذي يزعج واشنطن
والغرب من هذا التقارب
اخيرا ما التاثيرات المحتمله لهذا التقارب
على امن المنطقه خصوصا في حال حصول طهران
على معدات عسكريه واسلحه متقدمه من روسيا
والصين في اطاره
[موسيقى]
في تصريحات اثرت الكثير من التساؤلات بين
المراقبين بشان سياقاتها ودوافعها
وتوقيتها كشف وزير الدفاع الايراني محمد
رضا اشتياني عن ان بلاده تتمتع بعلاقات
عسكريه جيده مع الصين وانها تبحث حاليا
معها بيعها مسيرات ايرانيه وزير الدفاع
الايراني اكد ايضا ان العلاقات بين طهران
وبيجين وموسكو يمكن ان تحد مما سماها
الاحاديه الامريكيه والغربيه في العالم
وفيما يخص صفقه مقاتلات 35 روسيه اكد
الوزير الايراني ان بلاده لم تتسلم بعد
هذه المقاتلات رغم اكتمال الصفقه من قبل
اما بشان ما يشاء عن احتمال شراء طهران
منظومات اس 400 الروسيه فقد نفى الوزير
ايانيه لدى بلاده شراء هذه المنظومه واكد
ان لديها ما يكفي من المضادات الدفاعيه
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من طهران علي
اكبر داريني الباحث المتخصص في الدراسات
الايرانيه الامريكيه ومن فيرجينيا معنى
ماثيو المستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه والاستاذ في جامعه جورج تايم
اهلا بكما فيما وراء الخبر وابدا معك سيد
علي اكبر داريني
هذا التقارب الذي تحدث عنه وزير الدفاع
الايراني بين بيجين وطهران ما الذي اراد
قوله تحديدا ما هي الرساله التي يريد ان
يرسلها ولمن
ايران تحسن من علاقاتها مع الصين وروسيا
كجزء من سياستها في التوجه نحو الشرق هذه
سياسه تم دعمها خلال فتره
عند انتخاب الرئيس الرئيسي منذ
سنتين وزار وزير الدفاع ورسالته واضحه
للغايه ايران تريد ان تكون مصدره للاسلحه
وهي تنظر الى تلك السياسات وبالنظر الى
هذه السياسات هي تسمح لها بتصدير الاسلحه
الى دول مثل روسيا والصين ودول اخرى من
ضمنها دول الجوار وهذا
مصمم بدايه وهذه السياسه مصممه من اجل
مكافحه ومواجهه العقوبات المفروضه على
ايران وعلى الطغيان
الغربي ايران قد
جمعت الكثير من الخبرات في مساله تطوير
المسيرات والمعدات العسكريه الاخرى هي
الان تنتج المسيرات التي باستطاعاتها
ان يتم استخدامها من اجل جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه او المسيرات التي تشبه
صواريخ كروس يعني هل الامر اسمح لي على
المقاطعه اريد ان انقل هذه النقطه لماثيو
وكرونك الامر يعني يتعلق بتصدير السلاح
فقط يا ايران تعرف قبل غيرها العالم كله
يعرف ان هناك توتر بين بيجين وواشنطن
وواشنطن بلا شك تراقب هذه التصريحات كيف
تفسرها في هذا التوقيت
انا ما رايناه منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا ان العالم قد انقسم الى ثلاث
معسكرات اولا ولايه المتحده وحلفائها هم
موحدون اكثر مما يعتقده الكثر وايضا راينا
هنالك الاحكام المستبده الفرديه كوريا
الشماليه وايران وروسيا وايضا لدينا ربما
حركه عدم الانحياز التي لا ترغب باختيار
طرف اخر بالتالي اعتقد ان واشنطن
قلقه حول هذا التقارب والتعاون بين الصين
وروسيا وايران وهي دول معاديه للولايات
المتحده وتستخدم القوه العسكريه من اجل
تغيير الوضع في العالم بالتالي الامر مقلق
ايران تعطي روسيا الاسلحه التي تستخدمها
في الانخراط في هذه الحرب الدمويه ضد
اوكرانيا بالتالي مره اقرا هذه قضيه
تراقبها واشنطن عن كثب بقلق ولكننا نتحدث
الان عن بيجين والحديث من وزير الدفاع
الايرانيه عن بيع مسيرات سيد علي اكبر
داريني الى بيجين في وقت فيه شد وجذب كبير
بين بشان تايوان هذا الاعلان في هذا
التوقيت
ما الذي في الواقع يريد قوله الوزير مره
اخرى اسالك تصدير سلاح فقط
لا يقتصر على ذلك
ما كان ما قاله وزير الدفاع
يهدف الى تصوير الصوره الحقيقيه للعلاقات
الايرانيه والصينيه والتي لا تقتصر على
التعاون الاقتصادي لكن تغطي مجالات الدفاع
والامن هو يرسل رساله الى الغرب مفادها ان
ايران الان
هي لاعب عالمي بامكانه ان يلعب ان يبيع
الاسلحه او يشتري الاسلحه من بلد مثل
الصين وهي الان تعمق علاقاتها الامنيه
والدفاعيه مع دوله مثل الصين وهذا
يعطينا انطباع ان العالم يتحول نحو نظام
متعدد الاقطاب واذا اريد ايران بالتاكيد
تريد ان تستخدمه وتنتهز الفرس للوضع
الحالي وكما يتطلب امنها
القلق او الازعاج الذي كنت اشرت اليه قبل
قليل السيد ماثيو
بدا في الواقع بسبب
ما قالت اوكرانيا ان
روسيا تسلمته من مسيرات ايرانيه طبعا
ايران نفت الامر وايران تدرك كل هذا الجدل
الان
وزير دفاعي يخرج على الملا ويقول ان
طهران ستبيع مسيرات الى بيجن
ما درجه القلق لدى واشنطن واي رد فعل يمكن
ان نتوقعه هنا
قلقه واحدى بواعث القلق الموجوده لدى
الولايات المتحده هي الصراعات
الموجوده في اوروبا وايضا في اسيا بامكان
هذا الصراع الموجود في اوروبا قد ينتشر
عبر الحدود ويشمل دول النيتو في نفس الوقت
الصين قررت اذا ما قررت ان
تغزو تايوان والذي يعتقد بامكانيه حدوث من
قبل العديد من القاده الغربيين بالتالي
الولايات المتحده عليها ان تتعامل مع
حربين كبيرتين في نفس الوقت بالتالي ايران
تزيد من سوء وضع الامور عن طريق بيع
الاسلحه لتلك الدول وهي ايضا على مشارف في
بناء
برنامجها وتطوير برنامجها النووي وهو
الاكبر ربما في الشرق الاوسط بالتالي
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها عليها ان
تتعامل مع تلك الدول الثلاثه بصعوبه الان
يعملون سويه بجانب الايجابي اعتقد ان
هنالك محددات لهذا التعاون ومستوى
الحكام المستبدون لديهم ربما مشكله ثقه في
الحلافات
المعمقه لا اعتقد ان الرئيس الايراني
والرئيس بوتين والرئيس الصيني لديهم
الكثير من الخلافات بالتالي ربما هذا
سيكون مقيدا
للتعاون المعلق لكنه باي حاله من الاحوال
يمثل تحديا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحدي للولايات المتحده علي اكبر داريني
وواضح في تصريحات وزير الدفاع الايراني
يقول ان التقار بين هذه الجهات الثلاثه
للحد من احاديه
الاحاديه الامريكيه والغربيه
والسؤال هل فعلا طهران تموضعت في هذا
الحلف الصيني الروسي في مواجهه الغرب
يبدو ان ضيفنا من طهران لا يسمع سنحاول
العوده اليه اعود اليك سيد مافيو
يعني في النهايه كان ضيفنا من طهران قد
المح في اكثر من اجابه الى ان طهران بسبب
العقوبات التي تواجهها بسبب الموقف الغربي
من ملفها النووي كل هذا يجعلها تبحث عن
شركاء عن حلفاء اخرين لماذا ليس من طهران
الحق في ان تبحث عن تحالف جديد وها هي
تعلنه صراحه
طهران
يحق لها ان تبحث عن حلفاء جدد اعتقد ان
ربما سيكون من الافضل لو ان ايران ربما
كانت لديها حكومه افضل بدل التي تركز بدلا
من تصدير الارهاب وبناء المنشات النوويه
وايضا زعزعه الاستقرار
للدول الجوار ربما من الافضل لها ان تتخلى
عن برنامجها وتحترم حقوق مواطنيها لكن
لسوء الحظ هذا هو ليس العالم الذي نعيش
فيه بالتالي واشنطن يتوجب عليها ان تتعامل
مع هذا الامر كان هنالك ضيف يتحدث عن عالم
متعدد الاقطاب لا هذا الامر ليس صحيح
الولايات المتحده ما تزال تمتلك حوالي 60%
من اجمالي الناتج المحلي ايران وروسيا
والصين يمتلكون حوالي 19% بالتالي
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ما يزالونهم في
موقف متفوق حتى لو ان الصين وروسيا وايران
عملوا سويه
اذا ما الذي تستطيع ان تقوم به اعتقد ان
بامكانها ان تقوم بثلاث امور اولا
الولايات المتحده ستزيد من انفاقها
الدفاعي من اجاكونا لديها جيش يتمكن من
التعامل مع تلك الدول الثلاثه
المتحده ستحاول ان تعتمد بشكل اكبر على
الحلفاء ولا قد راينا حلفاء في اوروبا وفي
اسيا يعيدون بزياده الانفاق الدفاع لديهما
ان الولايات المتحده ستعتمد بشكل اكبر على
الردع النووي والذي ما قامت به الولايات
المتحده خلال الحرب البارده عندما واجهت
الاتحاد السوفيتي القوي واعتقد ان الردع
النووي سيكون عنصرا مهما في التعامل مع
روسيا والتي تاتي تقوم بتهديدات النوويه
والصين التي تقوم بتوسيع ترسانتها النوويه
وايران ايضا التي الان هي ربما تبعد عن
ايام قليله من وجود امتلاكها امكانيات
نوويه خاصه بها
اذا في وجه هذه السيناريوهات علي اكبر
ديني في وجه هذه السيناريوهات ما الذي
يمكن فعلا لهذا التعاون الايراني الصيني
الروسي ان يصل اليه في الواقع يعني في
النهايه هذا الموضوع واضح انه
يبدو على الاقل كانه نتاج لحرب اوكرانيا
هل هو فعلا
كذلك ام ان هناك تحالف قابل للاستمرار
استراتيجيا
يونايتد المتحده
كانت قد عادت ايران والصين وروسيا في نفس
الوقت هذه هي المره الاولى التي يحصل فيها
مثل هذا الشيء في التاريخ الحديث هذا
الامر يجعل من هذه الدول الثلاثه حلفاء
طبيعيين وهذا قد سمح
لدول الثلاثه تلك ان تتقارب مع بعضها
البعض والتوقيت مهم جدا لان العالم الان
يشهد تحولا نحو عالم متعدد الاطراف وايضا
بوجود روسيا محاصره بهذه القوى الغربيه
هذا الامر يجعل من ايران روسيا وعلاقات
ايران والصين اقوى لان الولايات المتحده
قامت بمد عمقها الاستراتيجي الى اوكرانيا
من اجل احتواء روسيا وهي ايضا تحاول ايضا
ان
مدى نفذها الى تايوان من اجل احتوائه
الصين ونفس الشيء بالنسبه لايران بالتالي
تحت هذه الظروف تلك الدول الثلاثه تقاربت
مع بعضها البعض وايران تحتاج الى العمله
الصعبه
وبالتالي هي اصبحت مصدرا
للاسلحه منذ فرضي
وايران ايضا لديها عقود دفاعيه مع تلك
الدول يجب ان تحترمها ولكن سيد علي اكبر
ديني بغض النظر عن القلق الذي يمكن ان
تثيره لوشن ويبدو ان طهران لا تحسب له
حسابه ولكن ماذا عن القلق بالنسبه لدور
دول الجوار الخليجيه وهو الامر الذي
لطالما اكدت طهران انها تحسب له حسابا
وانها تريد تهدئه الوضع الان بالحديث عن
اسلحه وطائرات سخوي التي اكدت ايران انها
لم تستلمها حتى الان ولكنها اكملت الصفقه
هل تحسب حساب لما يمكن ان تثيره من القلق
في الخليج
هي ربما متاخره عن جيرانها في مساله
امتلاك القوه الجويه جيران ايران قد قاموا
بشراء الكثير من الطائرات الحربيه
المتطورات المقاتلات الايرانيه القديمه
يجب ان يتم تحديثها ولم تتمكن ايران من
القيام بذلك لعقود من الزمن شراء طائرات
35 هو ربما ستكون
سيكون ربما التحديث
الاول لطائرات الايرانيه في الوقت الذي
قامت فيه ايران ببناء هذه المسيرات
المصنعه محليه من اجل تعويض هذا النقص
النقص في قوتها الجويه بالتالي هنالك
الكثير الطريقه ما يزال طويلا امام ايران
لكن ايران تنظر الى
هو يهدف لا تنظر الى جيرانها العرب كاعداء
لكنها تقوم
بتطوير بتهدف الى تطوير قوتها الجويه من
اجل ردع اسرائيل والولايات المتحده وليس
جيرانها العرب
الى اي حد
معنيه بطمئنه حلفائها في المنطقه الذين
ادى بعضهم انزعاجا من
هذه الخطوه من خطوه ان حصول
الطيران على هذه هذا النوع من الاسلحه
الهجوميه
ان الولايات المتحده وشراكاتها في الخليج
مهمه للغايه واعتقد ان رسالتي الى شركائنا
في الغرب ستكون انها مفادها ان هذه حاله
يواجه فيها الطيبون الاشرار
ساجادل الضيف الاخر اعتقد ان ايران تمثل
تهديدا لجيرانها ولديها نشاطات مزعزعه على
الاستقرار في المنطقه ولديها ايضا مخزون
من الصواريخ البالستيه وايضا هي قريبه جدا
من امتلاكي سلاح نووي بامكانيه ان تستخدمه
وتشن حربا نوويه في المنطقه الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها من ضمنها حلفائها في
الخليج قاموا بوضع اسس يعتمد على النظام
الدولي وقد ادى الى عقود من الرفاهيه
والامنيه والاستقرار ايران وروسيا والصين
لا يحبون هذا الامر هم يحاولوا ان كما
نعرف ان روسيا منخرطه في حرب مع جيرانها
وايران تدعم ذلك ودول الخليج قد استفادت
من قياده الولايات المتحده خلال العقود
الماضيه ساطلب منهم ان يظلوا في هذه
الشركات مع الولايات المتحده في الوقت
الذي ندافع فيه عن هذا النظام الدولي
المستقرض ضد الدكتاتوريه ايران بيجين
وموسكو
السيد علي اكبر داريني ربما كما يقال
بالانجليزيه الفيل في الغرفه دائما هو
اسرائيل واسرائيل ربما المستفيد الاكبر
هنا من تصريح كهذا من جانب وزير الدفاع
الايراني ويمكن ان يعطي حجه لواشن بكي
ربما تقدم على خطوه باتجاه ايران او ان
تقنعها بذلك ما تعليقك
النوويه خلال فتره قصيره
قال كان هنالك حديث عن
12 يوما اذا ايران ليس امامها خيار سوى ان
تقوم بتطوير وتحديد امكاناتها الرجعيه وان
تكون متهيئه لاي سيناريو واي خطوه قد
يتخذها الاسرائيليون ضد ايران اشكرك على
اكبر داريني البحث المتخصص في الدراسات
الايرانيه الامريكيه واشكر ايضا المستشار
السابق مافيو
من فرجينيا وهو الاستاذ في جامعه جورج
تاون والمستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه
اذا بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]